hello you're watching the press preview
it's a first look at sunday's
front pages and joining me tonight to
see what is making the headlines the
journalist and author
christina patterson and the pr
consultant alex dean a very good evening
to both of you speak in a moment first
of all though
let's take a look at some of those front
pages and as well as showing
father and son smiling broadly at each
other the telegraph quotes
prince charles's tribute to the duke of
edinburgh today
my dear papa was a very special person i
miss him
enormously and the express has a similar
headline in fact and points out that his
funeral will be held next saturday
at 3 p.m while the sunday times reports
that the prime minister will give up his
seat at the funeral to
allow another family member to attend
given coronavirus restrictions
the mail on sunday also carries prince
charles's tribute to
his father praising him for remarkable
and devoted service
to the queen and the country the mirror
highlights what will be a reunion for
princess william and harry their
headline
united in grief the people remarks on
the vehicle which will carry the duke's
coffin declaring land rover and
out and given prince philip was the duke
of edinburgh it's perhaps unsurprising
that scotland on sunday pictures the 41
gun salute held in his honor today at
the city's famous castle
while in other news the observer reports
that scientists are concerned that
regional covid 19 hot spots in the uk
such as in west yorkshire and the black
country as well could bring about a
third wave
now reacting to rachel blackmore
becoming the first female jockey ever to
win the grand national the star
asks bookies why the long face
i'm joined tonight by christina
patterson and alex
dean great to see you both thanks for
being here um christina
why don't we start with the front of the
sunday telegraph i thought it was rather
moving actually
prince charles's words a little earlier
he came out of the front door at
highgrove and without notes
addressed the cameras he said my dear
papa was a very special person
i miss him enormously he's not hugely
comfortable christina is he with
making very personal statements but
actually i thought he did rather well
i thought it was really touching i found
myself wiping away
tears and he just spoke from the heart
and actually i think you know we're kind
of seeing a different side as you said
to
prince charles at the moment and he made
the point or i can't remember he
said made that point when he spoke but
he has made the point
today that or somebody has made the
point on his behalf that of course
it's not exactly unexpected that a 99
year old and 10 month man should should
die but
it doesn't matter how old your father or
mother
are when they die the fact is that you
know they are your father or your mother
and they are irreplaceable and as it
happens
and has as has become clear in the past
hours but it's been clear for a long
time prince philip was
an extraordinary person and deeply
deeply loved and i think that has
genuinely taken prince
prince charles and other members of the
family by some surprise because the
press has been quite rude about prince
philip over the years and his so-called
gaffs and
the fact that he was you know so very
much himself and
and was determined and wasn't very keen
on the press and was determined to kind
of
not curb his personality but the fact is
he did cur his personality
in so many ways because he really did
devote 70 years of his life
to astonishing exhausting service so
i think he was an extraordinary person
and i think this is a
an important moment for us and i
personally feel quite sad even though i
never met
him and alex uh charles we know spent
time
with the queen yesterday uh it felt as
if he was really speaking on behalf of
the whole
family today with this uh tribute what
did you make of it
i think we got some glimpses of the
mature personality that will shape our
future king
and the way that he will appear in
public
but of course behind the um
or beneath the crown there is a man and
i'm afraid i know how he feels i lost my
father this year
and a son if he's very lucky gets to
look up to his father as much as charles
did
as much as i did to mine and i thought
that his tributes were um
struck just right because it was very
revealing about his own love
but also reflecting his father's
position
in our country i found it um i don't
think just because of my own
circumstances i found it profoundly
moving
yeah totally understandable uh alex and
we're sorry for your loss as well i
i didn't know that um just looking at
the front of the sunday express
christina
more details today about the funeral the
nation
to fall silent at 3 p.m there will be
a moment silence before that funeral at
windsor and it's going to be a very
different
funeral to the one that was planned but
in many ways i think
perhaps philip would be rather pleased
i agree i was just going to say that i
think that he would actually be secretly
quite thrilled that he couldn't have
this
huge fuss made of him because he was
clearly a man who didn't
want a fuss made of him and genuinely
thought he didn't warrant it
so i think and the fact that boris
johnson has given up his
place because of course numbers are
limited to 30 at the moment means that i
think it can genuinely be
a really intimate family occasion of
course there will be cameras there so
there's a limit to how intimate these
things can be or indeed any
royal occasion that has a degree of
state
um relevance as well as family relevance
of course but
i think you know he he he was someone
who he genuinely devoted his life to
service he devoted his life to the queen
and that's one of the things that has
moved me most actually
i it was always evident that they adored
each other
um i've been lucky enough to meet the
queen a couple of times and
she was surprisingly beautiful actually
and and i mean
beautiful because she's much more
beautiful in real life even than she
is in photographs but you can see she
has
huge wit and sparkle and personality and
he very clearly did too
and what what's clear was that they had
a very real
solid grounded and joyful relationship
and that's a lovely thing to see in
anyone doesn't matter if they're royals
or not but it's
particularly touching when it's the head
of state and her husband is 70 years
yeah well said
um and alex uh you know i thought to
with the queen
uh tonight aren't they the second night
on her own without the man that's been
by her side
for so many many years yes a remarkable
support to
her majesty um for more than a long
longer than my lifetime
um it's extraordinary really isn't it
um philip larkin wrote in times
when nothing stood but worsened or grew
strange
there was one constant good she did not
change
and he wrote that about our queen on the
occasion of her silver jubilee
and here we are now so many years after
that and and it
is if possible even truer today and it
was enabled and made possible because of
the man
by her side they were a remarkable team
um doing these things
together and i think i i read the oath
he took
as her liege servant on the coronation
um committing to take on all manner of
folk by her side
and didn't he just i thought they were a
remarkable pair it must be
so hard for her now um without him and i
must say actually i think the papers
have done
him proud i've been very sad to see some
fringe people on social media um having
a go but i think most
outlets and mainstream uh news are as we
are today christian and i with you
jonathan united in in respecting
the sacrifice and life of service made
by prince philip yeah well said
um and talking uh about
grief the front of the sunday mirror
christina has the headline united in
grief
um and it would be rather wonderful
wouldn't it if if william and harry can
perhaps patch up their
differences by coming together there is
talk that they may well
walk behind the coffin in windsor
yes i mean i have to say that has been a
very sad
incident and whatever side you were on
and i don't think you needed to be
on side any side in particular
it was a very sad thing to watch
to see the pain that was caused to so
many people
and i would understand why william would
be desperately upset and feel
somewhat betrayed by that interview with
oprah winfrey
and i'm sure that harry did it in great
sincerity
and felt great pain himself but the time
has come to put that behind them it is
slightly unfortunate timing that it was
just
weeks before prince philip died and i
think the death of a parent i mean
nothing i know
from when both my parents died of course
it brings you closer to
a sibling and i i really hope
that the bad blood that has emerged
between them
can now be put to rest because
even though harry has chosen essentially
to leave the royal family and its duties
behind
they will always be brothers and they
both went through a terrible grief when
they were children i don't think any of
us who saw it
will ever forget those two boys walking
behind the coffin of their mother
in front of the eyes of the whole world
so i hope that
this repeat of that walking behind a
coffin will
go some way to starting to heal those
wounds
yeah the uh the last time we saw harry
with the family in public was uh the
commonwealth service
westminster abbey in march 2020 alex
quite some time ago
do you think um differences can be
healed
well we've got to be fair and say we
don't quite know
the extent to which this is the stuff of
media speculation beating up
um a rift between brothers who have
most of the the time that they've been
in the public eye seemed very close
actually and i um recalled all too well
and
the point that christina rightly makes
about them walking behind their mother's
coffin
and then the queen mother um these
moments punctured in our national life
these punctuation
uh points of of grief and i thought that
the um
the cover you were talking about here is
very good um not least because the queen
herself said earlier this year about
coronavirus that grief is the price we
pay for love
and i'm sure that that is a thought that
gives her comfort now
and i hope it's the sort of thought that
brings these two uh young men uh closer
together and i
just as to what christina says i don't
think we need to take sides particularly
between them and it's not this sort of
occasion when you do
even if you did have a side yeah um and
finally let's finish with the front of
the sunday people
uh christina i'm not sure about the
headline particularly land rover and out
but the idea that uh philip designed
this land rover to carry his coffin is
is rather lovely isn't it it's a
defender one three zero
gun bus apparently
i think it's wonderful i mean i think
prince philip was
always in some ways and eccentric and
in many other ways very much ahead of
his time and
loved uh technology was keen you know
kind of embraced tv
when it was a relatively new thing and
and of course uh
in sort of pioneered that uh
fly on a wall film about the royal
family so i think it's
i think it's wonderful that his
personality will feature in his own
funeral in this way
and he's quite right we should all think
about our funerals
you know it's good to plan these things
my mother left very precise instructions
when she died and and it helped i i
wanted to know that i was giving her
the funeral that that she wanted to have
and i'm really pleased that prince
philip will get the funeral that he
wanted to have so you know great good on
him okay we must leave it there and
head to a break but for the moment
christina alex thank you uh coming up
we'll move away from raw matters and
discuss
a historic day at the grand national
join us often
welcome back to part two of the press
preview christina patterson and alex
dean still with me
um alex let's turn to the front of the
observer um
scientists warned virus hot spots could
lead to a third coved wave and of course
we're all hoping that the vaccination
program has been such a success that it
will
beat back any potential third wave yes
and what is hinted at in this story on
the observer is that
these concerns might lead to criticism
of our unlocking on monday
and an attempt to keep us in lockdown
for longer and the great frustration for
those of us keen to see us
out of lockdown as soon as possible
which is most but not all of us
some people seem to have loved lockdown
but most of us like to get out of it
the frustration is that the goal posts
seem to keep moving as they do in this
piece
you know first we said that we needed to
make sure that we had the vulnerable
people who were most susceptible um
vaccinated and that's pretty much
happened in this
country now then we said we needed to
get the rate down and that's happened
now
then we said we needed to open the
schools and then leave a gap to see if
schools being opened
would be okay and that's happened now
without a blip
in the rate going up and now it seems
that some people
still still still want to deny us a
return to normality
we've got to get back to normal lockdown
is terrible for people's health as well
as for
the economy it's not just lives against
money it's lives against lives the
piling up of cost in
mental health and the harm to
individuals in lockdown is extraordinary
chris we've got to get out of lockdown
and this is really unhappy times when
people publish something like this yeah
sorry to interrupt alex um christina
um you know one day we get a scientist
warning with third waves on the way
last week scientists were saying
actually we should be all right
i think there's just so much uncertainty
surrounding this whole thing
there were some very alarming
predictions last week about a third wave
and i must say i felt pretty
disheartened
by them i think we just don't know i
think an awful lot will depend on
variants actually because they are
worried about the south african and now
nigerian
variant and there have been tens of
thousands of tourists who've come into
the country who have not been
quarantining and of whom there is no
trace they don't know where they are
they haven't tracked
them down and of people who are meant to
quarantine at home
only one and a hundred are checked up on
so
apart from the hot spots where there are
people living very
um closely together often in
multi-person households
and where they apparently often don't
self-isolate because
they feel they can't afford it and that
is a real worry
it seems to me that um the chief worry
is variance and
that will be more of a worry when we
open up travel now obviously i'm
desperate to go on holiday i think we're
all desperate to go on holiday
but um but that you know given that the
oxford vaccine
and millions of us have been vaccinated
with the oxygen vaccine
is not particularly effective against
some of the variants
that that's a big worry okay listen just
going to mention the front of the daily
star alex
why the long face bookies aren't happy
rachel blackmore what an achievement
fantastic dave i think it's great for
racing um first woman to win the biggest
challenge in
uh british horse racing and i think the
fact that buggies took her
an absolute beating was pretty
predictable actually given her
run of form i thought it's fantastic and
i hope that many people
are enthused with the sport as a result
of seeing this
and seeing that it is absolutely open
for a woman to win it and i think she's
going to go on to have
even more success in racing after this
so great news